we were here today with Katherine
McNamara to talk about her new movie I
am so excited now spirit yes is this
something that you grew up with did you
love the original movie what is your
connection oh of course I love the
original movie I was obsessed with the
original movie and then when I fit when
this role came along I went wait a
second
they made a TV show and I could be in
the Christmas special what is it
happening it's a dream come true
first of all to be in an animated
Christmas movie based on one of my
favorite childhood films it's incredible
and you're like I can't do this audition
because I am at home binging the show
Shirley Shirley I'll be there in a
little bit let me catch up know it's
such a fun movie and the show itself is
so beautiful because it really is just
about friendship and adventure and
horses and it's it's lovely but the
Christmas special brings it all home
because it ties in the holidays and not
only that but how music and the holidays
can turn any situation into a hot one of
holiday cheer all right that's my
opening because so much track record of
steering this subject when Jojo was here
with us Tooley like what would you do
with the Irish are we gonna get a
musical episode you get to be a singer
in this one I do how was that it was so
much fun music is something that I've
been dying to get back to for so long
the the showrunners of Shadowhunters
were kind enough to put one of my songs
on the soundtrack of the show in one of
our season finales and it did really
well people really responded to it
but I've been fighting demons or you
know bad guys of all kinds for about ten
months a year I had a lot of time to do
music so getting to do this kind of
reignited that spark for me so I'm
counting that for two for the musical
episode I'm trying to sum it into
existence
oh I'm so in for me okay everybody else
has done it let's go oh I feel like it's
faded because in my mind Buffy led into
Smallville and like thematic elements
and then Smallville brought us this
amazing universe so it's do that if
Whedon gave us a musical episode it's
right there it better be like I want to
see Grant doing some sort of shimmy
around as the flashlight that sounds
like behind the scenes of crisis on
Infinite Earths true because you know
I'm used to being on arrow which
everybody's you know it's a very dark
show it's pretty and it's like badass
this set the other and then I go on to
the other shows and grant and Melissa
I'm among my people this is amazing and
Tom Cavanagh the ultimate prankster and
madman on every set now doing something
which is animated gives you a lot more
freedom and like you're in a boost and
you get to just like play with voice and
all those things was it like the
preparation different between like
putting on a crazy skin tight suit
jumping around like how did you shape
those worlds I would say the preparation
is different in that you're limitless in
what you can do and that's why I love
animation I love voiceover so much is
because you're not limited by your
physicality you can literally do and be
and create anything that your voice can
do so it's that's why I kind of try and
get back to it as much as possible
because who knows what I'm gonna be
tomorrow I can be you know an amorphous
blob or a animal or a you know
singer/songwriter cowgirl but always
resurrecting always know I am a big fan
of animation in that it can kind of like
sneak in moral values and things that
are like shiny object oh wait I learned
so much yeah and I think superhero
content does the same there's always
like an underlying message and all these
things and you graduated college at 17
and high school super early I love that
you're like the shepherd of education
how important that is to kids that it
means the world to me
thank you what would you want people to
get out of this movie what message you
want them to receive I think out of this
movie because there's a lot of literal
and figurative chilling moments in this
and a lot of harrowing things that
happened to these kids and ultimately in
the end it's about sticking together and
being a team and about turning any
situation into one of positivity and
holiday cheer by getting through it
together with music and love and
togetherness I love that 30-second
commercials all I needed all in sound
bites that's why we're here folks
so you've been learning I think a lot of
lessons about teaming up to get a
greater goal done we have to it's here
we're collider heroes we're in the
middle of a crisis true crisis on
Infinite Earths which is the absolute
legendary one of the sacred texts of
comics you all are doing it right now
we're all trapped mid cliffhanger
how has this been for you it's been such
a dream come true
truly because you know having watched
all of arrow in preparation for coming
on to the show given who my parents are
to know the history I wanted to pull as
many little nuances from each of the
characters to sort of be this
amalgamation of two characters that
people loved so much and that have been
so dutifully and well crafted by Steven
and Emily for so many years but then you
know I've watched the crossovers for
years and it's you know I always wanted
to get invited to the party
and I'd was this year and I was so
honored truly and then you know to have
my supersuit revealed and to be on set
with a couple of super men in the flash
a great arrow at Batwoman and then you
know I get to play with the cool kids my
own supersuit it's uh it's really really
amazing and just to watch all of these
different worlds and characters interact
it's been so fun to explore particularly
because Mia is so much like her parents
getting to interact with people like
Sarah Lance who knows Oliver so well but
also so similar to Mia that they butt
heads in a lot of ways but can also
connect or Mary Ellen who knows Oliver's
aggressive tendencies can see them in
Mia and kind of manage her in a very
real way but you know these characters
kind of help guide her through the
biggest crisis of her life in that you
know her father has been her biggest
vulnerability and she was finally
confronted with him had to come to terms
and kind of make peace with all of her
issues with him and then to have him
torn away from her so quickly and now
she's on a spaceship among aliens and
strangers and superheroes dealing with
the biggest loss of her life it's a lot
and and it's a crisis all her own that
she's dealing with in the midst of the
world's ending and that's one of the
beautiful things about this story is
there's a hundred different through
lines and everyone gets their own arc
and every one is dealing with the crises
of some kind how did you find that in
her on the page because I can't imagine
like this half page we're going over
here and this is on the spaceship and
all those things how did you isolate her
own experience for you it's kind of how
I break down a script every time
especially one that's so epic in
proportion I'll read the entire thing to
get the overarching story and then I
because I'm such a storyteller I
get caught up in the story every time I
have to kind of remove the other pages
and just see where Mia goes see what her
through-line is and see kind of what
effects her directly throughout the
story and then tie everything else in
but it's the writers from day one with
Mia have done such a beautiful job of
crafting her story and making it really
special and really nuanced and and
well-developed and and that's been such
a great journey to go on especially
given what it's leading to and kind of
everything that the legacy of the green
arrow is it's a lot too close one
chapter and potentially begin a new one
and I just want to do justice by that
and that that ties perfectly and I've
been calling it a canary verse going
forward and the canary verse is really
really exciting I don't want to know
anything because I hate spoilers and I
love living in that world I don't tell
us perfect good I'm always terrified of
accidentally funny because I want to
watch the third course when you found
out that was happening just us as an
actress how did that feel like what was
that moment for you it's amazing to get
to take on this legacy because Steven
has built such an incredible legacy and
through with the writers and the team
it's it's a character that people
connect so much with he's the ultimate
antihero in the sense that his entire
story is one of redemption and he's come
so far and grown so much and you know
Mia has to in in smaller increments and
getting to sort of take that on it's a
big step and it's it's they're big boots
to fill as it were but it's very
exciting to see kind of where things can
go and and to see such a gritty badass
superhero played by a tiny blonde girl
is it's a fun new twist on a classic
superhero trope and I'm excited to show
people what we have in store we are
counting the days until we get to see
all of that good stuff but we haven't
had a chance to talk to you since you
took on this role what was the journey
for you like was there a day that you
found out what was up was it a long
process was there a moment it was a
gradual process with a very rip off the
band-aid beginning as it were because as
you know with these shows they keep
everything tightly under wraps so when I
auditioned it was for a character that
interacted with green arrow and wild dog
who was a rookie cop who you know is a
rookie cop who's very by the rules but
has a dark past
or something you know whatever they say
to keep it seriously so once I've got
the role then I started doing research
on okay so I'm in the SCPD so what is
that all about and what training do cops
go through and what does that happen you
know in Heaven's store and then I got a
call from Beth Schwartz who's our
showrunner she says hey congratulations
I'm so happy that you're on the show
we're excited to have you by the way
everything you know is it a lie you're
Oliver and Felicity's daughter kids form
English words to come out of my mouth
what I was so floored because I knew
this character had a potential to stay
on the show but I didn't know in this
capacity and having been on
Shadowhunters for years and with Malick
being such like a huge ship olicity was
always there in every essence with it
and so I knew the power of the olicity
fandom and I knew how much people
attached to that that ship and to those
two characters and everything and I knew
I had my work cut out for me but I
didn't even know her name for a long
time Wow like they I had no idea what
her name was
the first episode I did they only called
her black star but at that point I
thought her name was Maya and then there
was a whole different backstory that
different than what we had for episode
12 moving forward and they as they
developed the show they kept changing
things and honing in on who she really
was going to be and it turned out so
beautifully in the end and similarly how
did you find out about spirit was that a
phone call like how do you find out
you're an animated character I can't
imagine like that is normal I was
actually going into my voiceover agent
to tape a bunch of different voiceover
auditions and this one was one that
hadn't been sent to me because it had
just come in they handed it to me when I
got there they said hey this is other
one it's for a singer-songwriter are you
sing right so you know you just have to
make up something for these couple of
lines and then you know send us some
samples of you singing later and we'll
figure it out I mean okay cool
yeah this is fun and I went oh this
characters really I like this a lot and
then I get a phone call they were like
hey you've got this thing and it's this
and here's all the info by the way
you're gonna record the dialogue on your
way to set to arrow and a couple days in
Vancouver's
you know you're gonna get up early and
do that it's gonna be great
but it was a great process a long
process of recording it you know I did
the dialogue about a year ago and then I
did the music about eight months ago and
then little bits and pieces and every
time I go back they have a little bit
more of the animation in there and done
and ready so you get to see a little
peek into what it's going to look like
in the end and that informs the
character so much as well so the more I
the more the animators kind of give us
the more we give them it's this kind of
back and forth so it's really
interesting I think two of the goals as
a kid is to see yourself animated and to
see yourself in a super suit no but
those are definitely two milestones I
mean putting on a super suit and going
to work - it's kind of the ultimate goal
truly it's it's such an interesting fun
experience because you really do feel
like a superhero yeah I want to jump and
bound around and do all these things and
Vancouver looks like a super city like
it's got green on the skyscrapers and
it's so surreal and Vancouver always
like the CW captures Vancouver in a way
that is it's so specific it really does
and I mean there's so many iconic sets
like the Waverider and I may or may not
have fangirled when I first walked into
the arrow bunker for the first just had
a moment definitely Jojo was there for
that moment I think that was the first
day I met Jojo - and I think he thought
I was probably a little strange because
I walk in the aerbook I drink coffee
cafe jitters and I definitely just sat
there like looking around like ah this
is the friends felt like every time like
and iconic coffee shop is so oh it's so
true it's so true but that's that's
what's so cool about the arrowverse is
it creates these really iconic
characters and iconic moments and worlds
and earths that people just love so much
and it's it's a great way to throw them
all together and then you know sprinkled
Tom Ellis in there a couple times
because why not one of the things that
distinguishes DC on the comic book side
has they they've always been the company
that does legacy characters really
really well and so we often talk about
how the arrowverse TV shows are doing
things that we thought only could be
done in
and I feel like you are going to be a
defining example of a legacy character
happening before our eyes on television
is there anything about DC's legacy or
like that the entering that world
obviously you're not new to strong
fandoms indeed any particular highlights
from like walking into that side of the
mythology it's really interesting to see
because there is such a rich mythology
and so many different versions and
little pieces of characters that have
been pulled into the arrowverse and
similarly with Shadowhunters we did that
a lot by pulling in different pieces of
books and throwing in little Easter eggs
for fans so I have a real appreciation
for that but something I love about DC
in particular is that all of the
characters have such interesting and
often dark backstories and there's
something in there as an actor to mine
for everyone and that you know that's
that's been the joy and the tragedy of
fleeing Mia is that she was raised in
such a interesting way and and had so
many obstacles because of that and
because of her relationship or lack
thereof with her father she had a lot of
resentment there and a lot of anger and
abandonment and loss in just even having
him in front of her so even having a
connection with him became very
difficult but eventually obviously they
worked through that as she was able to
see and understand why he made the
choices he made and as she's becoming a
hero herself she begins to understand
what that really means and and that it's
ultimately all about sacrifice and about
loyalty and about legacy and about you
know doing what's right no matter how
hard and that's kind of what all these
heroes do on the show and that's kind of
what crisis is all about another good
like I think beautiful sound with the
things we haven't seen yet again I hate
spoilers but I love asking people their
favorite thing they filmed we haven't
seen but in one word so when we see that
moment we'll remember this was your
favorite thing in the future I have to
think
I'll tell you this we haven't yet seen
Mia with her hood up and it's coming so
hood and there's an there's an element
to that that is also new that is
exciting and fun and I had a hand and
helping to create amazing thank you so
much for joining us today we can't wait
for the rest of the crossover and I have
one last question because it's a
Christmas special what is your all-time
favorite Christmas movie okay I'll give
you two okay three because I love
Christmas movies
Irving Berlin's white Christmas elf
Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer the
perfect trifecta I love it all right
check out your new favorite Christmas
movie check out spirit I am so excited
I'm all-in
this is this is great congratulations on
the animation and the super suit in a
span of like eighteen months and we'll
see you after all the crisis madness
let's do it all right